good morning john four years ago today i
was in
the hospital very tired and a little
anxious and very happy
to have a healthy baby boy and a healthy
wife who was now a mom while i have
pictures and videos and even some audio
files of that time
they don't tell though a whole story
that you can find in another way in some
ways a more true story and in some ways
a more personal story definitely creepy
it's a little mind-blowing but i can go
back in time in my google search history
and see what i googled
on that day and i googled a lot some of
it i'm proud of i watched a lot of
youtube videos about how to swaddle a
newborn baby
i also googled the etymology of swaddle
because that's a cute word some of the
things are a little embarrassing but i
get it like i for example oren was like
90 percentile in body weight when he was
born but like 50th in in head
circumference and that made me super
worried no one told me to be worried
about this i was worried nonetheless so
i googled a ton about this turns out
within like three days his head size was
normal it was just that his head was
really squished
because he had gone he'd been burned i
think there's some learning i could do
from that like
the things that i am most worried about
when they are most
new and i have the least data are often
the things
least worth worrying about and then
there are some things that i'm like oh
i have no idea why i googled gay culture
otter because apparently i needed to
know about that like right then when my
son was less than a day old
guess the minutes go by and you get
bored like somebody everybody else is
sleeping
and you're wondering about things but
there's also a ton of stuff that i do
not really know how to feel about
because the context here of course is
that my son was born
in the days leading up to the 2016
election a thing i was very worried
about and so there's lots of stuff about
donald trump there's also stuff about
huma abedin's laptop do you remember
this cause like i don't there was
something about
hillary clinton's assistant's laptop and
it felt like a very big story but as
with
oren's head size it was something that
we had very little data on so the story
really
wasn't the thing it was our anxiety
about it
and that turned out to be a legitimate
thing to be worried about just worried
about the worry like with this anxiety
about unproven unknown levels of
maybe corruption would that lead people
to make faulty judgments that we would
then have to live with
for four years or for ever i want my
searches from that day to have all been
the cute ones or the useful ones breast
milk storage guidelines uh
sample birth announcements great how do
i know when my baby is done pooping
because i'm pretty sure that i thought
he was done pooping and i took his
diaper off and he wasn't done pooping
and then there's just this search
one word oren catherine's granddad's
name we had not yet named him that
and so i was searching baby names and i
guess get out me carvine is also fine
but i don't want to have been thinking
about donald trump on that day but i was
and maybe i shouldn't have been
but maybe i should have been i didn't
know how to be a perfect dad when i'd
been doing it for a day i don't even
know how to be a good human and i've
been doing it for 40 years i don't
always know how to engage with a world
that has changed
so much over the last four years of my
child's life i do know that it's better
for having him in it
and i think it's better for having my
worry in it worry for his health and
happiness worry for the health and
happiness of
the rest of us too i think i looked up
these google searches because i don't
really know
how to handle this moment for me this is
going to be a rough weekend it
might be a rough few weeks but also i
know that
none of this is going away i'm very
worried about this election but it's not
going to be the end
of the pandemic it's not going to be the
end of injustice and inequality
not going to be the end of conspiracy
theory it's not going to be the end of
hyper-partisanship and it's not going to
be the end of the fear and the anxiety
and the anger that a lot of people
experience whether justified or not but
at least let's all promise to keep
worrying for each other
and also occasionally googling the free
shivaka do vine
john i'll see you on tuesday tuesday